l'informatique savoir pouvoir et
libertés invité de notre journal simon
aura renault au mans une victoire
technique et économique
le retrait israélien du liban les
casques bleus dans un étau l'attentât au
club méditerranée
jean pierre bloch ce nouvel acte de
terrorisme nous inquiète
mais monsieur bonsoir jamais en 24
heures une voiture n'avait réussi à
dépasser les 5000 km sur le circuit du
mans jamais on était arrivé à cette
moyenne de 210 kilomètres heure jamais
on n'avait bouclé un tour furent rapide
sur le circuit de la sarthe
trois records tombent trois records
renault renault qui avait patiemment
ruminer sa revanche après l'échec de
l'an gagné face à porsche renault qui ne
reviendra pas l'année prochaine car 24
heureusement cela coûte cher très cher
et vous êtes sans doute très nombreux à
vous est demandé comme nous en quoi une
régie nationale qui fabrique des
voitures de monsieur tout le monde
pouvait bien être intéressé par le fait
de se frotter aux grands monstres du
type porsche ou ferrari
quel intérêt pour cette marche qui ne
marque qui ne fabrique pendant que de
petites cylindrées et bien la réponse il
faut d'abord la chercher dans
l'expérience compte actif des ingénieurs
de chez renault en perfectionnant un
nouvel équipement le turbocompresseur
le turbocompresseur est une pompe qui
gavent les cylindres de mélange
air-essence alors que dans un moteur
conventionnel appelé aussi moteur
atmosphérique c'est le piston qui aspire
se mélangent le turbocompresseur permet
donc d'augmenter dans de très fortes
proportions la charge à l'intérieur des
synapses l'intérêt d'un tel équipement
réside dans le fait qu'une voiture de
tourisme de faible cylindrée équipée
d'un turbo peut avoir un comportement
tranquille et être relativement
économique en ville par exemple et sur
route dès que l'on monte les régimes se
comportait comme une voiture puissante
équipée d'un gros moteur alors la r5 de
demain serait-elle équipée d'un turbo
compresseur peut-être pas les moteurs de
renault 5 mai est tout à fait possible
de voir sur certains véhicules de la
gamme des solutions avec des
turbocompresseurs
c'est tout à fait concevable
concrètement et à part le côté technique
quelles sont les retombées économiques
et commerciales des 24 heures du mans
pour la régie des retombées commerciales
sont difficiles à mesurer directement
mais nous avons une politique qui est
une politique bien sûr fondée sur le
marché français mais également à 50% sur
l'exportation et dans seulement sur
l'exploitation mais sur les
implantations internationales de reno
nous considérons qu'il est très
important de voir le nom de renault
associé à des performances techniques
quand on s'attaque grand marché
international très concurrentiel en face
de concurrents étrangers puissant il
important de montrer que renault puisse
proposer des solutions techniques
adaptées aux problèmes
on sait que ça va vous faire vendre
davantage je sais absolument incapable
de vous dire c'est vrai nous avons une
voiture demain je sais que ça crée un
climat qui favorise râle
le développement des ventes dans la
composante technique et l'image est
certainement un des paramètres
importants
et oui il ne faut pas oublier le
prestige qui auréole un vainqueur au
mans le prestige à l'étranger en premier
lieu nous vous le disions les américains
par exemple sont très sensibles à ce qui
vient du mans et ce sera un appoint de
formidables vont renault qui dépensent
beaucoup d'argent pour s'implanter aux
états unis en ce moment il n'y a pas que
le marché américain
regardez l'exemple de la conquête de la
turquie et avec l'aude
à istanbul on brûle toujours les feux
rouges mais les embouteillages ont
changé de nature
ils ne sont plus fait seulement deux
grosses américaines des années 60
maintenant devant sainte sophie ou dans
les ruelles au bord de la corne d'or les
voitures européennes sont de plus en
plus fréquentes
pour une fois les français ne se sont
pas contentés de vendre leur marchandise
avec plus ou moins de bonheur
ils ont tenté de trouver des solutions
originales pour s'implanter à l'étranger
une usine d'automobiles
rien de plus banal mais celle ci qui
fabrique des voitures françaises se
trouvent à bure ça dure ça c'est une
petite ville située dans la partie
asiatique de la turquie sert 12 sont
donc fabriqué par une société turque une
société dans laquelle les français
possède une importante participation
cette année l'usiné de bursa produira 40
mille voitures c'est déjà plus de la
moitié de la production annuelle en
turquie le gouvernement présente neuf a
décidé de créer sa propre industrie
nationale automobile en conséquence ou
bien ont fabriqué ici ou bien on n'était
pas dans le marché du tout pour la
régissent une opération qui a coûté
serre est qu'elle est rentable
oui elle a coûté cher la régie mais
aussi aux deux actionnaires turc qui
compose d'un côté theolia chrono mais
elle est rentable maintenant et depuis
1975 de résultats sont positifs les
perspectives pour l'avenir est bien au
point de vue cadences de production nous
voulons atteindre les prochaines
quarante cinq mille voitures avec un
taux d'intégration de 85%
on en bout du 100 m la carrosserie
ensuite de passer à 50 mille ans 81 et
de passer à 65 milles en 82 et peut-être
ensuite développer encore notre
production pour le marché
première originalité de cette usine elle
est très intégrée c'est-à-dire que la
plus grande partie des pièces 85% sont
fabriqués dans le pays
deuxième originalité plus surprenant
encore la société oiac qui est le
principal actionnaire est en fait la
mutuelle de l'armée turque utiliser ces
capitaux disponibles en construisant des
voitures c'est sûrement une action
efficace dans un pays en voie de
développement
voilà donc qui a donné un peu de baume
au coeur des dirigeants de la régie
renault leurs préoccupations étaient
plutôt social conflictuelle ces derniers
jours la majorité du personnel a repris
le travail ce matin aux usine de cléon
et sandouville 75 % des effectifs à
cléon selon la direction un peu moins
selon les syndicats à flins les
grévistes des presses n'ont pas repris
le travail mais ne sont pas très suivis
par leurs camarades
un médiateur a été désignée la cette
usine et puis au mans la situation est
elle tout à fait normal mais demain il y
aura un débrayage de 24 heures enfin
chez berliet cette fois le travail a
repris ce matin à vénissieux malgré un
débrayage des caristes qui avait été à
l'origine du mouvement
et puis en ce moment même rené monory le
ministre de l'économie reçoit françois
gado clé et le pdg de manufrance il lui
soumettre son plan de sauvetage de
l'entreprise stéphanoise le ministre
guirassy lui accorde ou non un prêt de
20 millions au titre du vs enfin demain
ouverture des négociations salariales
à commencer par la banque puis extension
à 30 autres branches politique
maintenant une fois de plus sur la
sellette
un dossier qui reste maudit celui des
plus values de réforme en réforme on ne
retrouve plus grand chose du texte
original
les députés vont s'attacher une fois
encore à le modifier
ils ont commencé tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée alors pour faire le point
philippe sassier il y a plusieurs façons
de gagner de l'argent en bourse de ces
façons consistent à acheter des titres
au cours le plus bas possible et essayer
de les revendre aux cours le plus élevé
si cette opération réussit la différence
entre le prix d'achat et le prix de
vente constitue une plus-value
prenez un portefeuille boursier qui au
premier
l'envié d'une année vaudrait 50 mille
francs un an plus tard à la suite
d'achats et de ventes bien réussi la
valeur de ce portefeuille est passé à 60
mille francs
ce sont ces dix mille francs de plus
value qui pourraient être imposées à
condition qu'ils soient le produit d'une
spéculation
en effet le projet du gouvernement
établit une différence très nette entre
les boursiers professionnels qui se
livrent à de nombreuses ventes et achats
spéculatifs et les boursiers
traditionnels qui se contentent de bien
gérer leur portefeuille
dans ce dernier cas la plus value de 10
mille francs ne serait pas imposables
les portefeuilles modestes sont donc
épargnés par la taxation des plus-values
mais certains députés estiment qu'au
moment où l'on essaie d'intéresser
l'épargné à la bourse la taxation sur
les plus values est bien malvenue la
politique étrangère maintenant il ya de
moins en moins d'israéliens au sud liban
heure après heure de nombreuses unités
de l'armée isralienne repasse la
frontière le retrait définitif étant
prévue pour demain
petite bavure 4 fedayin ont tenté de
gêner l'opération en s'introduisant dans
un kibboutz en israël
il aurait traversé le jourdain l'un
d'entre eux a été tué et trois autres se
sont enfuis
l'armée israélienne a commencé
aujourd'hui de plier bagages du sud
liban la seule présence qu'elle
maintiendra et celles de quatre postes
d'observation mais pour les soldats de
tel-aviv
ça n'est qu'un au revoir ils ont promis
qu'il reviendrait si les palestiniens
tentaient à nouveau de s'installer à la
frontière sud
et pour le prouver quatre jours avant
son retrait officiel
l'armée israélienne a lancé un raid
éclair contre une base palestinienne au
sud de saïda
derrière les lignes des casques bleus à
40 kilomètres de la frontière
israël doit en principe remettre ses
positions du sud
liban aux forces des nations unies mais
sur le terrain il en va tout autrement
l'armée israélienne préfère confier la
sécurité de la zone frontalière aux
milices chrétiennes plutôt qu'aux
nations unies les chrétiens du sud qui
ont manifesté pour que les soldats
israéliens restent au liban n'ont pas
confiance non plus dans les casques
bleus et craignent le retour des
palestiniens
l'installation des forces de l'onu à la
frontière signifierait aussi la fin des
échanges commerciaux entre israël et les
villages chrétiens du sud
des échanges qui ont fait leurs preuves
économiquement et politiquement et
casques bleus qui viennent de recevoir
les renforts de 1500 soldats irlandais
sont aujourd'hui si mid met dans une
position inconfortable
pris en sandwich entre les milices
chrétiennes et les palestiniens
à chaque instant ils peuvent faire les
frais de nouveaux affrontements entre la
droite chrétienne et les fedayin car les
palestiniens le doigt sur la gâchette
n'attendent que le départ du dernier
soldat israélien pour tenter par tous
les moyens de se réinstaller le sud
liban à la frontière israélien
tahir étonnante confession de fidel
castro il aurait informé les américains
des 17 mai de l'imminence d'un projet
d'invasion chabat par les gendarmes qui
a tangué hilal castro qui aurait tout
fait pour s'opposer à ce projet et cela
repose le problème du rôle des cubains
dans ce conflit 0,61 oui on nous
disposons effectivement d'information
qui recoupe explique peut-être un peu
les informations américaines sur disons
la prudence éventuelle de castro mais
pour bien comprendre ces informations je
crois qu'ils font appeler un peu le
contexte ces fameux rebelles katanga qui
ont se sont emparés de kolwezi ici ont
un chef un chef option un patron répond
testé qui s'appelle natale bomba bien
hessenheim booba est un personnage tout
à fait extraordinaire figurez-vous que à
l'origine sonatel mumba il était chef de
milice privée de l'union minière du
katanga gérer les mines etc
ensuite il a été policier de tshombé et
il a même aux côtés des mercenaires
occidentaux il a combattu une rébellion
marxiste plus ou moins dans cette région
du congo ensuite il s'est engagé aux
côtés des forces coloniales portugaises
pour combattre les nationalistes noah en
angola
1 et je peux vous dire que je n'ai
rencontré à cette époque et c'était pas
du genre progressiste et ce n'est qu'à
ce moment là quand l'angola est devenu
indépendant qu'il a retournée kazakh et
qu'effectivement il a combattu au côté
disons des marxistes angolais est
effectivement à ce moment là cet endroit
là où il se trouve avec les hommes les
cubains l'ont entraînée et l'on armée et
il est donc devenu patron de ce qu'on
appelle les et gendarmes katangaise par
commodité de l'armée par les cubains
alors revenons à nos cubain précisément
vous avez de l'information annonce des
informations effectuant jette une
lumière un peu nouvelle sur la
personnalité de 7 ans qu'attendait la
première information c'est que un mois
et demi avant la tacc de kolwezi
il s'est tenu dans la capitale de
l'angolais bond à une réunion au cours
de laquelle les soviétiques et les
cubains ont fait pression sur ce chef
des quatre anglais en lui demandant de
s'unir avec les autres forces politiques
opposées aux mobutu à mobutu deuil parce
que yahia il ya des forces de gauche et
ancien lumumbiste oseille alors les
soviétiques et les cubains qui
manifestement ne faut pas très grande
confiance
ce combat long et de s'unir aux autres
forces de gauche il a totalement refusé
et s'en est suivie une quasi rupture
politique entre les cubains voiliers et
ses rebelles katanga un peu avant cette
attaque la deuxième information que
peut-elle encore plus important c'est
que ce fameux nathaël bumba toujours à
la même époque un mois et demi avant
l'attak a pris contact avec des
responsables de l'union minière il les
connaît bien et pour cause et avec des
personnalités politiques belges de
tendance conservatrice
il a retenu à curieux langage il aurait
dit vous savez d'accord je suis aidé par
les cubains par les soviétiques mais
vous savez ça ne prête pas à conséquence
moi j'ai pas changé d'opinion politique
croyez moi lorsque j'aurai gagné
lorsqu'il y aura les victoires eh bien
je défendrai vos intérêts vous pouvez
compter sur moi et il ajoutait que
mobutu était l'homme des français et que
lui est un grand partisan de la présence
belge
enfin dernière information rapidement à
l'époque je voulais dit il l'avait dé
combattait du temps de tshombé il
combattait avec des mercenaires
occidentaux
le fameux bob denard qui seront
maintenant aux chômeurs et schramm et
bien certains de ces mercenaires
occidentaux continuent à collaborer avec
lui en angola où il se trouve
actuellement
alors vous voyez effectivement ça
expliquerait que peut-être les cubains
étaient plus circonspecte qu'on la
pensait d'abord après l'attentât hier
matin au siège social du club
méditerranée on se demande vraiment qui
en veut au club méditerranée d'abord des
hold-up l'an dernier parfois meurtriers
des incendies criminels trois attentats
en tout le dossier s'épaissit sur le
bureau de gilbert trigano le pdg et sur
celui des enquêteurs le mystère aussi
car l'attentât d'hier a été revendiquée
par un front de libération dont on
n'avait jamais entendu parler
un mouvement violemment raciste et plus
particulièrement antisémites alors voilà
deuxième question à laquelle nous sommes
efforcés de répondre
il y aura t-il dans la france de 78 des
relents d'antisémitisme est à cet égard
certaines affaires récentes sont assez
troublante
les manifestations de racisme sont
encore marginales pourtant déjà
inquiétante de nouveaux sigles apparaît
sans signature aux lettres aux coups de
téléphone pour vocation attentats
menaces et parfois on passe de
l'inscription allah allah sans traiter
de petit juif
et puis elle a sorti les carences
expliqué de la preuve de mon coca mais
souvent plus larvé l'antisémitisme le
racisme se présente sous la forme d'une
rumeur qui veut laisser entendre que des
juifs ou d'autres se sont rendus
coupables de délits y aurait des
grenelle a souvent de sa m ce soir le
puits que c'est la vérité
ça va tous et tout fait comme ça comme
ça se passe partout parce que l'histoire
du racisme je pense que c'est bien à
l'époque ont des attitudes ambiguës de
certains qui prête à confusion
en somme celui qui n'est pas franchement
anti raciste est raciste il sera
récupéré par ceux qui ont intérêt à ce
que des races des religions des hommes
se combattent cali a souvent un intérêt
caché quelque part l'argent le sexe la
politique par exemple peut-on éliminer
des concurrents commerciaux
c'est la rumeur d'orléans peut-on faire
tomber une municipalité
c'est la rumeur de dreux avant son maire
françoise gaspard alors insisté
aujourd'hui à une recrudescence du
racisme
il a toujours existé on peut pourtant
parlé de points de racisme ne trop forte
concentration travailleurs immigrés un
climat social détérioré vont provoquer
la poussée de fièvre fatale dans une
période de crise économique
tout est facile les idées simples
touches les ans un audit par exemple un
million et demi de travailleurs
étrangers
il ya un million aiguilles chômeurs et
bien haut mais les étrangers à la porte
et y aura plus de chômage comme vous le
voyez c'est facile on oublie que ces
travailleurs étrangers ont pris quelques
fois des places que les français ne
voulaient pas prêt mais c'est plus grave
pour nous c'est la renaissance de
l'antisémitisme
c'est un fait et nous ne devons pas
prendre à la légère
prenons les choses au sérieux le 1er
juillet 1972 le parlement unanime
votaient pour la première fois dans
notre droit français ne lois qui
répriment expressément le racisme mais
la difficulté d'évaluation d'un délit de
ce genre rend souvent impossible sa
répression
expulsion il ya quelques heures de l'ami
canadienne de jacques mesrine jocelyne
deraiche venait d'être libéré ce matin
la prison de fleury mérogis il est tout
de suite reparti manu police yari pour
montréal japon encore un tremblement de
terre aujourd'hui un séisme très violent
19 morts sur la côte pacifique de l'île
de hon dos c'est à dire la plus grande
et la plus peuplée de l'archipel
un colloque la paris pendant deux jours
sur l'informatique sous l'égide de la
fondation frederich bull inauguration
d'un nouveau système d'ouverture des
portes dans un hôtel parisien demain à
l'hôtel hilton avec cette petite carte
magnétique qui désormais remplacera les
traditionnels clé de chambre je pourrais
multiplier les interventions les
interpellations quotidienne de
l'informatique dans la vie de tous les
jours il se passe autour de nous des
événements fondamentaux qui sont la
vraie révolution du 20e siècle et nous
n'en vendons presque jamais content
alors de temps en temps il faut
s'arrêter et faire le point comme
viennent de le faire pendant deux ans
deux auteurs à la demande du présent
arrêt public simon aura et à la main que
le fruit de leur réflexion est paru il
ya quelques jours à la documentation
française sous le titre
l'informatisation de la société et 20000
exemplaires ont déjà été vendus à tel
point que l' ouvrage va sortir en livre
de poche et c'est vraiment le type de
lecture quand l2 vous recommandent
pendant l'été alors avec nous l'un des
deux auteurs donc simon aura une
première question qui est une définition
dictionnaire qu'elle laissait
télématique dont vous nous parler
presque de part en part
c'est l'histoire d'un mariage d'un
mariage entre ce qu'il était convenu
d'appeler des ordinateurs ont chacun
sait à quoi ils servent des calculs les
classes dans l'information
et puis des moyens de transmission nous
sommes en train de vivre ici la
télévision le téléphone et coiffant le
tout
l'organisant demain les satellites c'est
à dire d'une façon générale les
télécommunications alors gare il domaine
précisément ça va changer ça va changer
la vie de tous les jours
eh bien ça va en fait répandre dans le
grand public d'abord dans les
entreprises dans les grandes
acquisitions des gens partis mais dans
les petites puis dans un certain nombre
de professions libérales par exemple
terre javaux cas les médecins peu les
médecins sûrement l'enseignement plus
lentement pour des raisons qui ne
tiennent pas la technique et chacune de
ces professions va trouver se trouvait
successivement transformé par l' usage
de ces machines qui seront ou les
connecter des branchés sont des petites
machines comme les machines à calculer
vous à l'élan vous servez chez vous ou
bien branché sur des réseaux et là le
point est intéressant car ces réseaux
pour brancher ces terminaux ne
constitueront par exemple votre appareil
de télévision sur d'immenses base de
données les elfes est nouveau c'est que
ce mariage va permettre marié à la
constitution des nappes des bases des
données un accès de plus en plus large
allez stop de connaissances à des
mémoires collectives dans lesquelles
seront stockées tout ce que les
intéressés désir constant alors vous
dites ça à transformer des professions
ça va les toucher même très directement
dans la mesure où il va y avoir un
chômage considérable
si vous retirez le travail des
enseignants de certains médecins
des postiers c'est assez inquiétant dans
cette évolution
oui je crois que c'est pas du tout comme
ça que ça se pose je compte d'abord ça
va aller plus lentement que
l'imagination de permettre de prévoir
dire ça se calcule en année en dizaines
d'années
ça ne se calcule pas parce qu'en réalité
ce sera le temps de réponse d'une
nouvelle technique ou plutôt le temps de
réponse d'un certain nombre de
résistances à lyon les techniques et la
société ne se laisse pas violer comme ça
par les techniques les gens s'adaptent
rompre massivement donc je crois que
c'est la sphère des dix quinze vingt
prochaines années sans augmentation
conséquente du chômage mais non dits un
instant vous savez quand on a inventé le
métier jacquard on allie qu'il n'y
aurait plus de travail dans le textile
pour les ouvriers textiles
on a remplacé
et l'eau comme les fiacres par des
locomotives s'est imaginé que c'était la
fin de l'emploi dans les transports bien
aujourd'hui il ya plus de transport et
il ya surtout du fait de la productivité
accrue dans chacun de ses moyens une
foule d'autres services d'autres biens
qui sont nés et dès aujourd'hui on peut
certainement dire que si l'informatique
constitue comme je le crois
un outil de productivité considérables
pour les années qui viennent il va
permettre de résoudre le problème de
l'emploi pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
le problème de l'emploi c'est un
problème de déséquilibre de la balance
extérieure en fait y'a pas besoin dans
ce pays et donc on pourrait employer les
gens à satisfaire ses besoins ce qui
gêne pour mener une politique active
dans la solvabilisation de ses besoins
dans l'augmentation des salaires dans
les allocations qui permettrait
d'acheter des biens ou des services
c'est que on est éprouvant à l'idée de
déboucler commerce extérieur je vais
vous donner un exemple
les statistiques montrent que quand on
augmente la production d'un point on
augmente les implantations de points
supposer un instant l'épreuve est brute
du productivité permettent de gagner un
franc sur le commerce extérieur
cela veut dire que c'est de francs qu'on
pourra mettre pour créer les emplois
nouveaux
mon aura vers qu'elle se situe cela va
nous conduire est ce que c'est cette
société inhumaine qu'on imagine un petit
peu avec le coeur froid d'un ordinateur
est ce que ça vous paraît être le
meilleur remède à cette société bloquée
que vous dénonciez ya quelques années ça
ne nous conduira de nulle part en soit
la bonne question c'est comment la
société va t'elle conduire ces
ordinateurs sais pas du tout comment les
ordinateurs vont-ils conduire la société
l'ordinateur va pas de servir d'arbitré
entre
le capitalisme d'état entre
l'autogestion entre le mars l'ordinateur
est un serviteur efficace si les
serviteurs de gens qui ont envie de le
via sa société précis alors ça
d'instruments qui augmente sont à ce
titre les pouvoirs de pression de cette
société si on veut faire servir
l'ordinateur est une société
décentralisée infiniment plus humaine
plus relationnel plus convivial et bien
c'est certainement l'outil le plus
efficace pour le faire je ne crois pas
du tout que l'ordinateur soit un patron
il s'agit de savoir qui sera le patron
de l'ordinateur et à vrai dire la seule
chance d'avoir un bon patron dans cette
affaire c'est que l'opinion publique se
saisissent à ce point sur ce phénomène
nouveau cette dimension nouvelle qu'elle
ne maîtrise pour ce qu'il voudra et
j'espère que ce sera une plus grande
démocratie alors c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire l'an 5 minutes bien sûr on veut
pas épuiser le sujet en cinq minutes
mais nous essaierons de consacré à simon
aura son rapport donc l'informatisation
de la société toute une série
d'émissions dans question de temps à la
rentrée je crois que c'est un sujet
suffisamment passionnant autre question
vous posez que nous réservent les
programmes d'antenne 2 pour la prochaine
rentrée
eh bien c'est ce que nous a révélé
maurice ulrich notre pdg dans une
conférence de presse cet après midi il
présentait en effet aux journalistes les
nouvelles grilles pour l'été à partir du
21 juin et puis pour la rentrée à partir
du 18 septembre alors avec vous georges
dégoût et si on voit le détail de ces
deux nouvelles démissions
alors il faut souligner en premier lieu
que les programmes d'été réserveront la
plus grande place au sport à la fois
dans l'après-midi et dans la soirée le
tour de france pour bientôt tennis à
wimbledon et la coupe davis et ensuite
les grandes rencontres internationales
d'athlétisme des émissions nouvelles à
18 heures une émission quotidienne pour
les jeunes et avant le 12 le journal
télévisé de 20 heures une émission d'
yvan audouard l'heure d'été le lundi des
divertissements différents à 20h30 et le
dimanche jeux sans frontières
à noter également dans les nouveautés en
juillet les trois premiers jeux
une émission lyrique le mois de l'opéra
le quatrième restant le jeudi du grand
échiquier et en août
tous les samedis le mois du tiers alors
en ce qui concerne la rentrée les
grandes priorités a indiqué par le
président hendrik sont les suivantes la
création qui a toujours été l'apanage
d'antenne 2 la réflexion la jeunesse le
renouvellement d après midi le
pluralisme l'ouverture et la diversité
alors ses grandes orientations se
traduise en une grille qui respecte les
grandes émissions traditionnelles comme
les dossiers de l'écran apostrophe
aujourd'hui madame avec une édition
spéciale troisième âge le mercredi
fenêtre sur à 17h30 c'est la vie à 18h40
les stats de le dimanche à 19h les
changements seront surtout sensible de
dimanche où nous trouverons avant et
après le journal de 13 heures le top
club de guy lux à 14h20 une série
française et étrangère suivie d'un
nouveau jeu de pierre bellemare
en savoir plus absolument voilà après le
journal de 20 heures toujours le
dimanche une série étrangère à la place
de musique une musique et un
documentaire de création en alternance
avec un homme un jour nous passons au
lundi le lundi soir disparition de la
tête les jambes au profit d'une émission
de variétés de 20h30 à 21h30 et à 21h30
un grand magazine d'actualités question
de temps ou cartes sur table programmée
jusqu'à présent le mercredi fallait
alors le mercredi précisément sera
essentiellement consacré à la jeunesse
de ses heures à 18h30 d'abord ensuite de
20h30 à 22h 15 avec le muppet show est
une nouvelle émission de patrice laffont
le maquereau l'histoire fera également
la part belle au sport et en particulier
au football alors voilà pour les grandes
lignes
on ne saurait tout tir en deux minutes
mais je pense que dès demain vous
quotidiens habituels entreront dans les
moindres détails
voilà ça c'est la complémentarité entre
la presse écrite et la télévision alors
après les projets de l'été le calendrier
des prochains jours à la télévision jour
de football essentiellement vous voyez
avec les matchs de la coupe du monde qui
seront diffusées par antenne 2 aussi
déjà à la première série dont qui
commence mercredi dès mercredi à 18h40
le journal aura lieu à 20h30
je vous laisse découvrir la suite et
puis vous avez une deuxième série qui
est la dernière série avec la finale la
coupe du monde qui sera retransmise en
direct par antenne
voilà donc pour les sept matches qui
seront
ensuite par antenne d epuis pour en
terminer avec le football sachez que
c'est l'autrice l'autriche pardon qui
était classée première du groupe 3
toujours en sport un record un petit peu
insolite celui de la traversée de la
manche en planche à voile ce record a
été battu par un français il a traversé
la manche en quatre heures et huit
minutes
fantastique exploit à compagnie accompli
pardon oui hier à vienne par le kenyan
que vous allez voir maintenant henri
renault il a battu le record du monde du
10000 m en 27 minutes 22 secondes et
cinq centièmes déjà détenteur de deux
records mondiaux celui du 5000 m et du
3000 m steeples ono a 26 ans et le
premier pour heures de tous les temps à
réussir un tel concours lui a dit me met
donc au nom vient d'améliorer de huit
secondes l'ancien record avec cette
prestigieuse panoplie il dépasse d'ores
et déjà les seigneurs c'était les
fourmis les attaques
henri renault va maintenant s'attaquer
au record du 3000 m
savez-vous ce qu est un tacot vous
pensez tout naturellement à une teuf
teuf à une de dion bouton pas
raisonnable et bien c'est aussi le nom
du cerf-volant au japon et les petits
parisiens ont pu apprendre pendant deux
semaines au centre beaubourg à les
confectionner
il était guidé par un maître venu tout
spécialement d'osaka m o qu'attaquer qui
fait partie d'un cercle très fermé
ils ne sont en effet que quinze au japon
a fabriqué ces tacots
couleurs lumineuses papier de riz
baguette de bambou le matériel n'a pas
changé mais au fil des siècles le
cerf-volant a perdu ses fonctions
primitive
on a oublié qu'il avait autrefois sa
place dans les cérémonies religieuses et
même à la guerre
les cerfs-volants ont fait leur
apparition au japon au septième siècle
mais c'est en chine qu'ils sont nés sans
doute bien avant et l'engouement pour ce
travail d'artiste pour la recherche de
la perfection est toujours le même mix
wahou qu'attaquer façonne 300
cerf-volant en une année mais tous ne
travaille pas au même rythme mais le
temps et surtout placé bien les choses
le faire bien s'il n'est pas si noir
dessus va pas ils regardent ou alors il
faut y passer combien de temps à ton
avis et bien-être en caoutchouc faire à
deux cerveaux pas pourquoi il faut beau
pull colorier comme ça pour qu'on voie
est bien quantitative endroit parce que
si ce n'est les tout petits pois
plusieurs centaines d'écoliers parisiens
ont appris à façonner ses oiseaux de
papier
le contact s'est établie facilement avec
le m ils ignorent l'autre langue
mais il affirme comprendre tous les
enfants bien mieux que les adultes à
osaka son métier c'est d'illustrer des
livres d'histoire pour les petits ici
l'histoire est au bout d'une ficelle
non
voilà la météo pour terminer un temps
assez beau sur la france aujourd'hui
avec des nuages sur le nord et le
nord-est et des orages sur le midi pour
demain vous le voyez même type de temps
toujours des nuages sur le nord et le
nord-est quelques averses sur les alpes
ailleurs le temps sera le plus souvent
soleil alors même 3h10 et patrick lecocq
qui vous présentera la dernière édition
du journal vous souhaite une excellente
fin de soirée les coûts de nos
programmes au revoir à tous à demain